nine and a half minutes into an almost
13 minute speech to the nation Iraqis
president Barham Salathe finally spoke
about the resignation of Prime Minister
Idol Abdullah Mahadi and holding
elections it was a yes but speech to
protesters yes Maddy will resign but
only once a successor is determined yes
elections will be held but only after a
new election law is implemented and a
new election committee formulated by a
Salwa Zahra the Prime Minister is
willing to submit his resignation he's
also asking the political parties to
find a replacement within the
constitutional and legal measures that
would prevent a constitutional vacuum no
timeframe was given from a Hadees
resignation or win elections might be
held since October 1st protesters have
been demanding melody stepped down and
elections held in 60 days monitored by
the UN to ensure their free and fair
until this hour the Parliament didn't
give anything to satisfy the rage of the
demonstrators they didn't give them any
hope at the very least the government
can calm the protesters by removing
Mahdi or having his cabinet resign as a
first step there were high hopes when it
was announced that President Saleh would
address the country on Thursday evening
instead there was greater anger and
resolve among protesters one called the
speech a joke this week the protests in
Baghdad have been fueled by students
many skipped school members of the
teachers and attorneys unions boycotted
work I asked my teachers why do we study
when we have an unknown future how long
can we keep silent we study hard to
graduate and then what we stay at home
Mahadi has been in office a year he was
a consensus prime minister after
wrangling in the parliament the UN
Special Representative in Iraq is urging
patience she says no government could
comprehensively tackle past and present
challenges in just one year
whether protesters heed that advice
remains to be seen Natasha Ghanim al
jazeera Baghdad